today we're talking about writing a
particle system in 3js
specifically we're going to be building
out a reasonably flexible system from
scratch
so that you can build something like
this with very little effort
or even this since it'll be really
flexible and you can do quite a bit with
it
now honestly 3gs doesn't have the
greatest particle support
it looks a bit weak at least from the
examples
if we go over to the 3js site and browse
the example section
searching for particles yields very
little in the way of concrete examples
i mean some of these are kind of cool
but the code mostly relies on either
points material or writing your own
shader
which is fine it does some basic
particles but the problem here is that
unless you're planning on the absolute
most basic particles that don't animate
or do much of anything
this isn't going to get you far so let's
make one ourselves
now just for reference there are some
third-party ones that various people
have written
in various states of support but writing
one yourself is easy
and if you're here you're probably here
to learn what we'll start with is a
super basic particle system
just getting the bones of one up and
running what i'll do
is get just a few particles on the
screen and nothing else
the first thing we'll be doing is using
the same setup we did in the video on
creating a basic 3d world
so i'll just copy that directory right
into the new one
start by defining a particle system
class and you need to do a few things
need to create a material need to create
a buffer geometry to hold the vertex
data
a list of points to be rendered and we
need to add it to the scene
next we'll define some particles we'll
make 10 particles to start
each with a random position once you've
done that we have this update geometry
function which just
iterates over the list of particles and
updates the buffer geometry object with
properties from the particles
separating this out as a separate
function will make much more sense
once we're animating parameters every
frame
lastly we need a shader so we'll start
with the bare bone shader here
the vertex shader just transforms the
position and sets the size of the point
and the fragment shader just samples the
texture
so with all that done we load it up and
here we have some particles on the
screen
first thing you notice that there's some
weird issues here
when i swing the camera around smaller
or further particles seem to be drawing
over top the ones that are supposed to
be closer to the camera
it's because they're drawn in the order
we defined them meaning we might draw a
close one first
followed by a far away one after and
since we're not writing out depth values
the one that's drawn second will
override the first one
let's start with just two particles as
an example it's pretty obvious from here
that one is supposed to be further away
than the other
depending on where the camera is if we
swing the camera around the right way
you can clearly see the further one
drawing in front of the closer one
let's go fix this luckily this is an
incredibly easy fix
we just sort the particles from furthest
to nearest in the comparison function
we'll compare the distance from the
camera to the particle
as a side note you can of course use
distance squared it's a minor
optimization if you know what you're
doing
just go for it but we're just going to
use distance for simplicity's sake
once we do that load check sorting from
both angles and you can see that it
doesn't really matter which side i view
the two particles from
they always seem to appear in their
correct order now
and if we go and put all the particles
back let's just bump this number back
up and see there's no weirdness from any
angle
let's move on to some more advanced
stuff now and add some parameters that
can vary from particle to particle
let's say that we want to vary the size
of each particle
there's a few things you need to do
first off we need to go into the shader
and add a size attribute
and then multiply the gl point size by
this
after that we need to go into the
particle definition and we'll randomize
the particle size
and then we update the geometry with the
size so that the value gets passed into
the shader
loading this up notice the size
variation
some of these are really big and some
are really small we'll add some color
variation next
so we need to go back in and it's a
simple matter of going back into the
particle system
defining color as part of the geometry
add it to the particle definition
here we'll randomize the rgb values
then you need to go into update geometry
and update the geometry properly from
the colors
after that you add support in the shader
by declaring a color attribute
then you declare a varying attribute
which is a way for a vertex shader to
pass
values into the fragment shader
in the fragment shader you essentially
want to multiply the texture's color by
the
particle's color and once you load it up
the colors are all appearing
i can just kind of spin it around a bit
but you can see there's a lot of
different color variation here
now let's make them fade and blend so
instead of seeing those black squares we
see something a bit more like smoke
first thing we want to do is just enable
blending and that's a simple matter of
changing the blend mode from no blending
back to normal blending
once we do that we can see that they're
partially transparent
but keep in mind that all we've done is
enabled the texture of transparency
we also want to be able to affect how
faded each particle is overall
so like the other attributes like color
we're going to be adding a new attribute
same thing we modify the particle
definition we modify how the geometry is
updated
in this case we're just going to pack
the alpha value along with the color
and change color to be a vector of four
floats instead of three
same changes to the shader we'll just
substitute those vector3 for vectors
once we run the resulting code you can
make out that some of the particles are
a lot more faded out than others
this is working out great but what is
all this work for
well what we've quickly built is a basic
particle system
and what you can do now is start
animating it so i'll show you how to do
that next
the way we can do that is by going back
to the particle definition and the first
thing we need to do is define a lifetime
for a particle
that gives you the ability to animate
over the lifetime changing the
attributes of the particle however you
want
for example i could easily decide to
animate the alpha of each particle to
start at zero
build up to one quickly and then slowly
fade away to zero again
then on top of that i could say decide
to start each particle as blue
make them red and then green as they
fade away so how do i do this
easily we can define a spline with
multiple points representing what color
or how
faded the particle should be at that
particular point in the particle's life
i've written this quick linear spline
class here and all it's doing is during
the update it's checking what fade or
color value should be assigned to the
particle at that point in its life
and of course you could get a bit more
variety by rotating the texture a bit
randomly for each particle so let's go
do that
what we're going to do is declare a
rotation here in the particle
declaration
we'll initialize it to a random value
between 0 and 2 radians
then we do the usual changes beginning
with adding an attribute
and then updating that attribute in
update geometry
now here in the vertex shader we take
the angle and compute the cosine and
sine
and pass it down to the fragment shader
here on this line we take the 2d texture
coordinates and multiply that by a 2d
rotation matrix
now look at this the smoke looks a lot
more random since we just randomly
rotate the texture a bit
hell you can even animate this back in
the code if we just
increment this by a fraction of the
frame time they should rotate a little
bit
loading this up pretty cool there's just
that tiny bit of movement that makes the
particle system look just a bit better
lastly let's make the move a bit so
we'll go and add a velocity to the
declaration of the particle
and then we'll just update the position
here each frame adding the velocity
times the frame time
and we'll also just add some drag here
just to slow the particles down a bit
this isn't a physically accurate
simulation just giving you an idea of
what could be done
let's add the fading back in as well so
i'll uncomment that
and this is kind of looking cool but it
doesn't really look like
fire does it what we need to do is
change the blend mode
now blend modes are a totally different
discussion altogether and 3ds supports
quite a few options here
but a really basic overview is that
there are two ones that are
often used alpha blending and additive
blending
the mode that we've been using up until
now normal blending is alpha blending or
what you'd use to do something like
smoke
if you want that glowy fiery look you'll
want to switch this to added blending
and when we do that
this is looking a lot more fiery you can
kind of look around this at different
angles and it's definitely looking a lot
better
so i'm going to load a rocket model in
now and i'll make a few quick changes to
the particle system code
we'll animate the size of the flames
starting small and getting bigger
and i do that by adding a spline for the
sizes specifying how big roughly the
flame should be at various point in the
particle's life
then i can sample the size here and
update particles and multiply it against
the current size
i'll make a few other small tweaks here
and there but mostly it's the same as
we've been working through
the big difference is i'm going to make
the flame shoot down
instead of up and here we go
once we do all of that this really helps
sell the rocket trail on this rocket
if we wanted to go even further we could
change the flames to turn into ash and
smoke
but that also requires us to dynamically
switch from additive to alpha blending
which is entirely possible with a more
advanced understanding of blend modes
but not today definitely in a future
tutorial
hope you enjoyed this make sure to like
and subscribe as always
leave a comment and especially let me
know if there's a subject you want
covered and i'll add it to my to-do list
like always code is available on github
grab it and work through it and i'll see
you next time
cheers
you